your Excellencies distinguished guests
friends of the University of Oslo it's a
great pleasure to welcome you to the
University of to the University I've
long after an emotional weekend most of
you followed yesterday's strong Nobel
Peace Prize ceremony it was touching to
hear Award winner sets coeternal testify
about her own experiences on August 6
1945 about losing clothes family as a
thirteen-year-old watching human
suffering closely how the radiation
affected both those that experienced
radiation directly and the generations
that followed a strong and clear time
witness we need time witnesses and this
era and the neighboring vessel has
frequently been used to witness both
past and present this fall on September
1st just mean barriers received an
honorary Doctorate at this stage various
fight corruption organized crime and
drug trafficking as well as the many
human rights violations that occurred
during Guatemala's 36 year civil war on
November 13th each tae-goo Sidon
received the University of Oslo human
rights price a Turkish academic and
human rights campaigner she was not
allowed to travel to Q from Turkey it
was present by escaped Skype giving
strong evidence of the situation in
Turkey today on November 26th guided
Gollum back and life just witnessed
about the situation in Norway 75 years
earlier a day when 529 Jews were
deported from Oslo transported by the
ship do now and later sent on to a
switch
Saturday December 9th we met a
delegation with survivors from Hiroshima
and Nagasaki in our Botanical Gardens
they brought seeds from trees that
survived the atomic bomb in 45 seats
that symbolize survival power and hope
today we are again assemble here in this
splendid table a place that has been of
large importance to the cultural and
intellectual life in Orvis since it was
inaugurated in 1911 it has been and
still is a central meeting place in the
region cultural and public life and in
fact the Nobel Peace Prize was awarded
in this very Hall from 1947 until 1989
we are pleased that the University of
Oslo Cancer Society by cooperating
across sectors and by being an arena for
dialogue academia role in society is to
encourage deeper understanding critical
thinking and free speech which is why
dialogue indeed is so important I'm
looking forward to the new Nobel Peace
Prize for him here today across dividing
lines and I would like to express my
sincere gratitude to the DeNoble
Institute for the cooperation and I will
now give the word two noble Institute's
director who love your stuff please
good morning this year's Nobel Peace
Prize for in Oslo across dividing lines
will address indigenous peoples rights
within the context of social justice and
environmental protection it is indeed a
timely issue first 2017 marks both the
20th anniversary or the adoption of the
UN declaration on the rights of
indigenous peoples and the 25th
anniversary of dr. Rigoberta menchú
receiving the Nobel Peace Prize in
recognition of her work for peace and
reconciliation across ethnic cultural
and social dividing lines still 25 years
later across today's world the rights of
indigenous peoples are frequently being
challenged disputed neglected this is
why the organizers of the forum has
decided to invite dr. leg-oh birth
dimension back to Oslo to reflect upon
the state of affairs concerning
indigenous rights twenty-five years
after her Nobel Peace Prize award what
progress has been made and what are the
unsolved issues and pressing challenges
ahead immediately following dr. Manchus
talk a six-member panel will discuss the
Standing Rock conflict in North Dakota
where oil pipeline interests have
clashed with the rights of the Dakota
Lakota Nakota
peoples and compare it to some extent
with the new seer
mine controversy in the municipality or
quarrelsome
in northern Norway a conflict affecting
the indigenous Sami population of the
region the panel discussion will be
moderated by fred de sam lazaro highly
respected correspondent for PBS newshour
one of the most trusted news broadcasts
in the United States as the theme across
dividing lines suggests this year's
Nobel Peace Prize forum Oslo is intended
not only to shed light upon the
conflicts and interests at stakes in
these conflicts but also to provide a
platform for dialogue and experience
shearing shearing on behalf of the noble
Institute I would like to express my
gratitude to our partner the University
of Oslo and your responses and events
partners new generation power and peace
through Commerce for their generous
support but now ladies and gentlemen it
is my great honor to introduce one of
the great champions for Indonesia's
indigenous peoples rights over the last
30 years a Nobel Peace Prize laureate of
1992 dr. Rigoberta menchú please take
the floor
[Applause]
good morning
es un placer estar aquí en go slow es le
bron doe este grandia en nuestro sagrado
calendario maya este dia NOS recuerda
que AMPAS algo en este Planeta me onesi
millones de ancestress abuelo c Abuela's
generaciones a muchas generaciones y lo
que NOS recuerda es que somos apenas una
generación y que el dia de mañana
seremos tambien Abuelo's yog wellas de
este Planeta por lo tanto nuestros
Abuelo's no recuerden que tenemos que de
haar un camino para las nuevas
generaciones para que continúa
su v de plana los abuelo SI las Abuela's
no Sam permitido tener Abuela's abuela
agua abuela animal Abuelo's Abuelo's
plant 'as los Abuelo's que no san beda
en este Planeta
gnosis Ito's tienen a - oh do you have
interpreter yeah okay
damos tiempo para que pagar Sousa - ah
si yo quiero Express are me profunda
gratitude especial maintain al instituto
noble IL committee novell por la
invitation es un gran homenaje a los
pueblos indígenas es un gran gomen ah
hay un premiere novel que receive emos
as a veinticinco años en esos bente
singko a knows effective Ament a an
pasado muchos acontecimientos
acontecimientos que por el lado NOS
permit a visual is our loss a vance's
especialmente Llosa vance's n materia de
derechos de pueblos indígenas
do mucho resultado el trabajo de
nuestros hermanos Y hermanas en el grupo
de trabajo sobre public Sione's
indígenas de la oh no en la conferencia
mundial de Vienna do mucho resultado a
la participation de nuestros hermanos en
las Ambler general de nueva york donde
SE creo l4o permanente de los pueblos
indígenas también podemos recordar el
convento siento Sesenta Nueve podemos
record are las décadas Internacional de
pueblos indígenas que added own agenda
especial para los pueblos indígenas
y los gobierno x' hemos visto en los
últimos a nose debate a mucho debate a
Internacional sobre los pueblos
indígenas
eso es muy positivo por que hace
veinticinco a nose no teníamos estos
instrumentos internacionales
no teníamos sunbrella torres speciale
sobre pueblos Cindy
Raina's eno teníamos reuniones Cumbres
adentro de las Naciones Unidas pero
también NOS a venti sink wonho's
estábamos de scooty end o SI adentro del
los ahorros de paz especial mente
ocurro's de paz in guatemala sink or
perova los temas de derechos identidad
de los pueblos indígenas y despues de
mucho devatas a la gran tambien algunos
Siqueiros de paz que hace una emphasis
especial a los pueblos indígenas
de tal manera que se habla Mo's de
derechos indigenas podríamos empezar las
referencia x' en el campo Internacional
en la nación suniye sin particular y en
algunos a scenarios de la organización
de Estados Americanos pero también
podemos ver en la corte interamericana
de derechos humanos kon kon hoon toda
resolutions victim inada sobre pueblos
indígenas especial mente se habla Mo's
de derechos territory allah's o que los
efectos the políticas extract Eva's
effect arimin los Pollos indígenas y
están en la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos Estadi Scootie end o en
el say no de la organización de Estados
Americanos la convención americana
sobre derechos de pueblos indígenas
nosotros somos parte Dez's dynamic --is
hace veinticinco a nose solamente
empezar Barranca el convento cientos
centenary yo I BMO's con conjunto distro
Mentos case producto de debate a case
producto de discusión
estos muy positivo
tambien a nivel nacional hay muchos
Ivanka's sobre todo que sera VA a los
derechos especific hasta los pueblos
indígenas
en el caso de guatemala lo Grom OHS que
los venti tres idiomas ma enza's se
convierte en idioma oficial aunt Ella
lay somos been Tetris idiomas Mayan says
sang creado various institutions como
mekinese Mo's para que vigil a la parte
de pasión de los pueblos indígenas osa a
un punto importante de definition t
agenda a legislativa de agendas de las
institutions Internacional a's lawson
focus yo recuerdo en estos días a
realmente a via UNF okay tam being in
loss loss plans cassia las Naciones
Unidas para el rey de Cerio
integral esto implica la participation
de los pueblos indígenas vemos entonces
UN con juntos de instrumentos ahora
vamos a otro Angulo de la realidad en
estos últimos veinte Cinco años y un %
ah hay de idiomas indigenas que ya sayin
perdido que ya no se van hablar por que
nunca tuvieran la oportunidad de
desarrollar sus lembas en estos bente
singko a nose BMO's un % ah hay de las
tierras
ancestral a's que también sayin perdido
muchos de ellos son resultado del despo
ho
della discrimination mucho de ellos son
resultado precisamente la falta de
políticas públicas donde i poem los
indigenas a univ Anza Internacional
important isa mo pero hay una realidad
nacional dramatic Oh
a preocupe ante por que mucho los pelos
indigenas tambien poco poco abandon
sous-sous Tierra's appeared in la
conexión con una gran civilization
ancestral algunos casos son despachos de
Tiaras Potro's es la falta de trabajo o
de vida digne de los pueblos indígenas
en las áreas especial mente or vanna's
vemos una gran Brecher entre la
definition Desiree chose the power loss
in the hennas y el complement o the
politicus públicas Havana fecn a los
pueblos indígenas el centro de los
problemas por lo menos en toda américa
latina es la tierra sigue siendo la
tierra el problema fundamental por un
lado los Estados no oto Guerin t2 lows
de propiedad asegurar a a las
comunidades indígenas y por otro lado
también la extraction de los bienes
Naturalis de los pueblos indígenas
causa nuevos scenarios de conflict owes
especial mint a el choque a con algunas
transnationals
que explodin de manera irresponsible a
la madre tierra en esto es más que otros
en el caso guatemala yo Co viendo c'mon
mayor problema de los próximos rao's la
tierra la extraction manera y especial
mint a por que las comunidades
no tienen beneficio de sa des Arroyo
case a plan Tia en sus comunidades o en
su país tenemos el grave a problema que
la meilleure cantidad de los recursos
que los Estados a signal
para la educación bilingüe intercultural
muchas veces cicada en la corruption in
la corruption no hace posible que llegar
los pueblos indígenas Oh Sal sabemos por
un lado los derechos de los pueblos
indígenas en la vida cote diana agron
des desafíos km Franta i grandes
difficult a lays a grande cebu toes i
sobre todo continúa en muchos casos la
criminalization de los de gente x'
indígenas pero por otro lado vemos chi
instrumento que es lo que tenemos que
hacer probablemente rebbit al-azhar UN
Agenda nueva para los próximos a OHS
especial meant a encontrar los mekinese
Mo's de aplicación de las normas
con las políticas públicas de los
Estados ela partecipation plana Activa
Ypres positiva de los pueblos indígenas
demanda que lo hemos venido tre endo
durante las últimas tres de cádiz em
particular tone de Mo's Cosimo's querido
casey construe yera
una ruta compartir de entre los estados
establecido z-- y las comunidades
indígenas esos diligent A's effective
Ament a el convento siento Sesenta in
Nueva Ecija
uno de los cambios mess in bacala's en
los pueblos indígenas en los últimos
veinte Cinco años en algunos paisa say -
voce lucha para que se oficial e se la
aplicación del convenience entos Centeno
EBA de manera constitutional en nuestro
spices a goat rose definitivamente el
convento siento Sesenta Nueve say
convertido en un instrumento appropiate
o por los pueblos indígenas
uri allison bajo el camino
a series de consulta en la población
estas consulta muchas veces no son bin
cool antes con el sistema legal sin
embargo son consulta scale AHIMA la
parte SE pacion de los pueblos indígenas
en el caso guatemala hemos hecho satan
tae Joos consulta popularise bajo el
convento siento centenary donde la
immense Amaya ria de la población bata
junto con los al caldez junto con la
utorid a local botton a favor de la
consulta inform ah de a plain ax pero
también botta a favor de llano
extraction day laminaria con a meto dos
que lastima la madre tierra okay destroy
a la vida con Kimiko's con otro tipo de
minerals que no significant desarrollo
para los pueblos indígenas hemos corrido
encontrar mode ellos poor ahem blow en
cuanto la la utilización de desarrollo
electrical pero muchos de las los mode
ellos que tenemos es que pasa la luz
cerca de la comunidad pero no I lose
para la comunidad entonces la gente no B
esto como una alternativa por ESO es que
muchas veces las Konfrontasi own a son
cada vez mayores pero yo soy una mujer
más optimistic yo creo que se hace been
kissing quanah's no teníamos la de que
la razón de principio 'he's Universalis
Desiree cholo pollo Cindy Kaunas no
teníamos la experiencia que significa
l4o Permanente en la nación a su Neda's
tan poco teníamos lo oportunidad de un
realtor especial y no teníamos la
participation directa de los pueblos
Cindy
Tiana's en muchos meses de negocio
Sione's a a las tenemos entonces podemos
Sekar mejor provecho para las future 'as
generaciones definitivamente somos una
generación que NOS toca la guerra Fria
que nos toca la violencia a mask Rowell
en nuestras familias en nuestro cigars
yoy o much's possibily Dada's del que
nova llamo zapper metier ese tipo de
valència en nuestras comunidades pero yo
veo Meza experiencia an America Latinas
porque los pueblos indígenas también han
sido parte de lo combos o locum Bulls o
que ha sido la stessa Sione's políticas
de noche ricky own a sin duda a un
Cahoon toda lead Roscoe Indiana k oi
esta haciendo su determine a co
esperamos venir a esta for o
tambien hacer una llamada a la commune
Internacional para que sigue respond
ando los de la gente indígenas donde
Kiera casting a siendo una lucha por sus
derechos es necesario respond r el
trabajo de los diligent a cindy ganas
hombres y mujeres por que suba taya no
es otro más que complement our una ruta
hace el futuro en estos bente singko a
nose yo a constitutional de la paz para
nosotros
fue UN reconocimiento profundo a los
derechos la lucha latte na cidade de los
pueblos indígenas significa goon
reconocimiento a los pueblos indígenas
donde Kiera case Teng tambien significa
un reconocimiento su grande ASA su
pensamiento su technolo
he su support s alemana da de un respond
o al futuro de las Esperanza's del dole
or Edel supreme en toda los propios
pueblos indígenas el premio Novell
tambien represent o un golpe Rotondo al
wrasses mo y la discrimination en todas
partes el premio noble volcko la mirada
asean los pueblos indígenas no Rigoberta
menchú sino la memoria collective
Adela's polos indigenas a por eso no
sentimos orgullosos test a premio por
que creer Mosca sento un Presidente
storico cane alt si la voz a los pueblos
indígenas la mirada del mundo hace a los
pueblos indígenas
y también la preocupación de las
Naciones Unidas para encontrar estos
mekinese Mo's que ya emos Mencia nada
para los próximos a knows los pueblos
indígenas Sigyn necesitan doe hacer una
hen de compartir de entre las Naciones
Unidas la cumbre international y los
pueblos indígenas yo quiero r ND roman
ah hey a la coopération norway --ga los
países Nordica's an sido an estado muy
presente en todos los proceso squamosa
Vado me Consta chain America latina en
wat Amala nuestros Aransas s gracias a
la coopération de los países nor Tico's
suecia en particular I inverted o muchas
furs o en accompany our la lucha local
Oh Cindy ganas inner Vega
esperamos que no Vega sigue siendo
lacunae de un rio de sol para los
pueblos indígenas del Planeta el
reconocimiento es usted agente z-- y el
acompañamiento de su sloosha's in cancer
blaze
también queremos Rendy Roman ah hey
Allah hemp low in crave like a
significant premium Noble para el apoyo
de la lucha de las mujeres nosotras las
mujeres hemos tenido una tremenda
participation and diverse campus in
gracias is despacio
yeah esta teri ma queremos poner en el
centro de este 4 oh and westeros ho
venus porque los jovenes no solo
necesitan la tierra no solo necesitan en
la participation plana sino también
necesitan de los conocimiento x'
necesitan profundis our only dare ask o
un leader roscoe para la paz porque son
nuestros susta two toes estos tres
puntos me parece a me fundamental para
este 4 o el reconocimiento a los
instrumentos else reconocimiento de una
realidad a impact on today lo polos
indiana's que sigue en viviendo en el
silencio yes reconocimiento de nuestra
Juventud hace el futuro no samos sentido
a company odd o con todas las luces de
todos los pueblos indígenas
y por ESO en domain ah hey a nuestros
hermanos que trabajar owned in canceled
mente en los últimos veinte cinco a nose
mo slow Grado también un nivel de
participación política yes a nivel de
participación política es una hemp lo de
que es posible a encontrar una ruta como
con todos los seres humanos del planeta
pero en particular
con nuestros conceded a nose donde
permanence a Mo's evil emos todos los
días la educación
la educación para la paz es otro de
nuestras demand 'as queremos que los
pueblos indígenas tambien grantees en su
propia
su propia and ammonia basada en el
llegado mess profundo que nos dejaron
nuestros ancestress es la plana tus de
la vida y lu cha Mo's pour esse
plenitude de la vida gracias a todos
amigos que yo veo que estan aqui
presentes gracias Auguste Ellis también
el éxito de la gente Indiana es una
realidad a pesar de la limit a Sione's a
pesar de los problemas que tenemos a un
éxito a eunuch emplo jana dia que seguir
para el futuro
Yodas año para este 4o las mejores
conclusions
aquella us Iggy Mentos venimos a buscar
una agenda consecutive Oh yo yo creo que
es posible que podamos seguir haciendo
intercambio z-- sobre todo mucho pueden
decir nuestras organizaciones in
nuestras autoridades ancestral 'as a
mucho spices las alturas ancestral a's
an Fortaleza dosoo participation yon
portal sido la enseñanza osseous us
nuevas generaciones ESO lo que no se
hace possible a estar aqui por que viven
las culturas del mundo que viven la
civilisation s ancestral A's
que Viva nuestros idiomas ek Viva
nuestra relatio Humana fraternal Yurman
OSA con nuestra madre natural issa como
empress ABBA oi nuestro sagrado de
Onofre cuerda que somos apenas Oona's
generaciones viviendo este Planeta
a depended a nosotros que tipo de
Planeta también de ha Mo's a las
generaciones
futurus EK mejor SI desde ahora
empezamos a trabajar nuestro relieve Oh
muchos mem preguntado en estos been
teasing guano's porque no I Otto in
Kanna Reza viendo el premio novel yo
dicho probablemente no mo since Crito
una candidate aura in muchas gracias al
istituto novel el comité a novel por
esta oportunidad de displaced the
receiver on premiere novel KX e kala
Belizean de las armas nucleus un 4o
sobre pueblos indígenas yeah me me
parece que estos una manera tambien
Denault a ser la lucha yell
reconocimiento a los pueblos indígenas
muchas gracias gnorga por su kirino's su
amor ustedes subpoenas son Cassie says
me Ana's davit antes de este Planeta
y sin embargo ustedes otra vez de la
memoria de dôme alfredo novel an hecho
una gran contribution alarm Anya
Universal ek siegen kanessa contribution
alarm Anya Universal muchas gracias
[Applause]
please
we would like to invite our panelists to
kindly take their seats and would also
like to invite up to the podium here
elder Tim Mintz two leaders leaders in a
brief prayer see here
I want to offer something that is gonna
take you back to my homeland the
indigenous nations of the Lakota Dakota
Dakota and do that sharing a part we
offer prayer that the Great Spirit will
listen to us that he will have pity on
us and the things that we're gonna talk
about today I'm a touch back on my
homeland of Canada North Dakota
understanding Rock reservation so my
relatives asked me to offer this and I
offer it and great humbleness to the
Sammis indigenous people of this land of
all the indigenous people that are
within this great halls here but also to
my relatives I want to say it in my way
also so I ask for forgiveness if you
don't understand what I'm offering yet
to do my heart
no Joshua danke Kotick Anita when are
the tacos in a ditch in harmony touch it
not governor occasion I'm knowledgeable
da cunha moustache to Richard the
production
hakuna would be work on hatred a
bedazzler top who openly what Colonel
Hatcher Walker
hatred to caution or not they work on
tequila Habakkuk I hate you you know you
know code to turn into one that's in the
over concrete a cogent accommodation
national security you know Jerusha my no
no no no no
Susheela for a honey no Kakashi no oh
yeah yeah when she no no no no no she
[Music]
oh hey
the cosmos Amala hey they're not that
she knows you know she don't we owe me
trust you know who should see man the
attention he took a okie up oh no she
loved I know so am I here homie talk to
you I see thank you
thanks very much for the invitation to
be here ole love thank you doctor Manchu
so many notable people here so many
notable people here so little time so I
will abbreviate or actually skipped most
of the formal introductions if you need
to know more about our panelists there's
abundant material on the Internet
perhaps it's enough in your in your
brochures I was asked to begin with a
few words of background to guide our
discussion today trying to narrow a vast
vast topic that dates back centuries and
I started to wonder on my first visit to
Norway from where I live in Minnesota
what might have happened if Christopher
Columbus had managed somehow to consult
with Leif Ericson it might have pointed
him in a different direction because he
was looking for Indians from my homeland
he wound up in the wrong hemisphere and
found some different people that he
called Indians anyway and it was the
start of a yawning divide between
indigenous communities in the nation
states that emerged on their lands and
it's a divide of course that is not
restricted to the new world as we'll
discuss later today today we'll visit
two very distinct theaters in this
divide to see if there are lessons to be
learned one from the other
or just globally and for those of you
not familiar I will add just a paragraph
each on the two cases that we're going
to be talking about today from which we
have several of the principles the
Dakota access pipeline straddles four
states from the Bakken oil fields of
North Dakota to Illinois for policy
makers who support it the project has
created thousands of construction jobs
about 40 permanent ones and fits with a
goal of US energy independence
construction of this pipeline was slowed
for months and years by protesters from
the Standing Rock Lakota community and
hundreds of sympathizers protesting a
pipeline that came very very close to
the main water supply source of this
community and protesting as well the
decimation of many sacred sites and
artifacts the resistance often met with
a harsh crackdown and at least one of
our panelists can attest to that
firsthand things seesawed through the
court and regulatory systems until they
screeched to a very abrupt halt after
November's election oil began flowing
through that pipe in June the other case
takes us to the northern Finnmark region
of norway where the new seer company is
all I've mentioned is proposing a copper
mine on lands inhabited by the Sami
people the sami parliament has opposed
the project concerned about the impact
on reindeer husbandry a traditional Sami
occupation there are also environmental
concerns about the plan to bury mined
wastes in a fjord that's critical to
salmon fisheries this project has also
seesawed for years between a Norwegian
government that has largely approved it
and the regional Finnmark Council which
sees it as an economic stimulus for a
region that needs one but continued
opposition from the Sami Parliament more
deliberations are likely so let's go to
our panel which is not representative of
all sides of the conflict the organizers
told me this is just not practical or
possible for a number of reasons and in
any event the purpose here is not to
relitigate these cases in each of the
disputes even though our panel is hardly
agree with one another in many cases but
rather in pursuit of crossing the divide
I want to go first to Grand Chief Edward
John
of the last in community in Canada
you've worked globally with the United
Nations and forging and indigenous
rights to self-determination it would
seem that the ground reality the
economic imperatives are just simply
overwhelming in such cases and the
outcome pretty much the same whether
it's in the US or in Norway which have
very different systems so like I have a
two-part question to start us out where
do you see hope for self-determination
and specifically what is it that
indigenous communities are specifically
seeking as the outcome in cases such as
this thank you
firstly your Highnesses and all friends
here
to my fellow panelists I wanted to thank
my sister regu Berta for the beautiful
words that she shared with us today and
I think she laid for us a very important
groundwork and what you did 25 years ago
and and today as well I want to
acknowledge your son's 23rd birthday
today mash congratulations
so Rigoberta talked about our youth and
there's a young lady her name is Anna
here she's the the Chiefs personal
assistant today she volunteered we're
talking about our youth and how
important we hold them up and we cherish
them and the future belongs to them as
we wind our way through through our own
respective lives and and so today I want
to say that I am from Canada where
hockey is king or queen and I do know
about Mats Zuccarello from this land
here
very good hockey player playing for the
wrong team the New York Rangers he
should be playing for Vancouver our
sister brought up the issue of
indigenous languages and she is right
the United Nations former Secretary
General Ban ki-moon said every every
week the two weeks one indigenous
language dies and that's that's a very
hard fact to undertake in in the country
where I come from our language is
forbidden our children including myself
were removed from our families from our
communities from our lands from our
elders we were brought into these
institutions called Indian Residential
schools and we were to be assimilated we
were supposed to be the instruments of
our own demise that we were to be
assimilated the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission which concluded its final
report in 2015 in Canada came to one
fundamental truth one fundamental
conclusion that Canada's laws policies
practices amounted to cultural genocide
this is in a developed country but
that's a history at the last hundred
fifty years I'll come back to that in
terms of the hope cross him crossing the
divide the divide firstly is historical
it is very deep
as my sister Rigoberto mentioned is
marred with assimilation its marked with
colonialism its marked with massacres
its marked with genocide its marked with
slavery and we it is our history we've
lived through that and today the
implications of the historical
relationships remain and so we find our
communities in a very dire situation
where social economic disparities are
very deep compared to the rest of the
population so we are working to find and
to work on solutions so we're looking at
this divide I was honored to witness the
ceremonies yesterday because there there
was discussion about another divide
between humanity and States between
States themselves in the situation of
indigenous peoples were talking about
the divide between the state and
indigenous peoples so there are
similarities the UN declaring the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
adopted in 1948 was in response to some
serious human rights violations and so
in nineteen 2007 seventy years later the
Universal Declaration of the Rights of
Indigenous Peoples was adopted and it's
a framework for building peace building
relationships and so I want to give an
example of Canada where when the United
Nations Declaration was completed that
the Human Rights Council in Geneva in
2006 the 48th member states voted and
Canada was a member then and Canada
voted no along with Russia the Russian
Federation I was there I was I was
heartbroken and so it went to New York
in 2007 the United Nations General
Assembly voted again and the board at
the General Assembly turned green there
were four red dots United States
Australia New Zealand and Canada
bordered No
and we were heartbroken again that our
own country would have bought it know
that these were developed states with
relationships with indigenous peoples so
we went to work back in Canada today
Canada has adopted under this new
government the United Nations
declaration without qualifications and
now there is a bill before the House of
Commons to to give life to the bill to
the to the declaration by legislation
and so we find ourselves in a place of
optimism that we will begin to address
the disparities that that do exist the
biggest conflict we find are in relation
to the rights to self-determination in
article 3 of the Declaration and the
rights to lands territories and
resources from articles 26 to 32 and I
the concept of free prior informed
consent where there is development to
happen in our respective territories so
I had the honor of visiting my sister's
territories last year a year ago and did
a report for the United Nations
permanent forum and what I witnessed and
she's in a way better position than I am
to tell that stories I wanted to to lay
out that framework that the Universal
Declaration and the rights of indigenous
peoples is the centerpiece now for all
indigenous peoples we work to over 27
years to get that declaration in place
it is also ours we cherish it and we
want the states to work with us to
implement it the United Nations
decorated Nations has developed has a
system-wide action plan where the
declarations embedded in the Paris
agreement sustainable development 20
plus 30 goals and but there's a slow in
the uptake at the state level at the
country level and so maybe I will leave
it at at that point thank you Fred the
second part of my question because I
think that's going to be a theme which
is specifically what outcomes
our indigenous communities seeking but
you've you've set the the broad sort of
agenda for us today talking about having
a framework in place to acknowledge
self-determination the devil is in the
details and the implementation which is
going to be another theme and the United
States did come around to signing
signing after initially saying no but it
didn't seem to matter to you Holyoke
Lafferty you were on the front lines in
the Dakota access pipeline controversy
where it's standing Rock and you have
the bruises physical and otherwise to
show for it
and I'm just wondering now that you know
essentially oil is flowing where do you
go from here and what energizes you to
continue where you're going is it's not
all over
I assume you go from here tell us what
all of chief just told matters when it
comes to put you know it didn't seem to
matter how make you happy hey Kaka walk
are we in my chippy my name is Holyoke
Lafferty
I am miniconjou Oglala and si tengo la
corte I am of the old Chetty shockingly
sacred fires I am very honored to be
here today and I and I'm grateful that
you're all here to hear the words that
were speaking and the stories that we
have to share I am one of over 800
people who were brutalized and arrested
during the Standing Rock resistance and
I am one of thousands of others who just
stood together who were able to listen
and and heed the call of our hearts to
unity
we heard the cry of the earth of the
water and we decided that we were
willing to put everything else aside
because we want life for the water we
life for the earth we want life for our
future generations so back to the
question here if you could redirect me
the hole that propels you in this battle
that would seem to the outside world was
lost if what we were trying to do is
redirect that pipeline it is where it
was intended to be that's been but you
have no intention to move on with
different pursuits of your life this is
a very central concern what gives you
hope that will continue to propel you
forward what gives what gives me hope is
that I am one of so many people we have
endured over 500 years of genocide our
preceding generations have experienced
so much trauma the government has come
they have stolen our children they have
stolen attempted to steal our culture
they have stolen our language they have
tried to kill the Indian in us we have
lived through generations of hopeless
situations where other people on the
outside looking in would things that
were insane for having hope that we
continue to carry on I can't explain to
you why or how but this is just the way
that we're made as indigenous people I
can say you know as the women of the
nations you know when we have our we see
our children that are afraid that are
that are fearful we're afraid to but we
dig deep and we find that hope we find a
way to provide inspiration for our
people to continue to carry forward the
fight that we have no other option we
are the life givers where the protectors
of the life for our children and our
grandchildren in all future generations
so
there is no other way but to find hope
so so for me it's it's a way of being
it's you know it's a way that it's just
the way that we are we it's who we are
to find hope so so right now at this
moment in history we are living
prophecies being fulfilled we have been
told you have had these teachings passed
down in our tribes and our communities
in our circles and you know we may not
share all of the details of those
prophecies a lot of them are known
pretty publicly but you know there are
other parts that as indigenous people we
have to you know protect the sacredness
of those things but we are living right
now the prophecies that have been
foretold and I believe that each of us
that are alive on this earth at this
moment in time we're here for a reason
we are all a part of this prophecy we
all have a responsibility to stand up to
have courage and to just do our part in
this big story of evolution the earth is
suffering the water is suffering our
people have suffered for so long but I
believe that we are in a time now that
we have the opportunity for a change and
and this has all been and this is all
bigger than us it's bigger than any of
us humans so you know I I stand just as
a servant to this prophecy to do what my
I'm responsible for as a local woman and
I see all of my brothers and sisters
globally doing the same thing Stephanie
Hope Smith you offered your services as
conduit if you will go between you have
seen the pain they divide the deficit
and trust the fact that communities that
leave very close to one another are very
foreign to one another on either side of
this divide what tools did you bring in
what were your goals
in the work that you did in this in this
particular and you know Dakota Pipeline
controversy well good morning to
everyone and to what a distinguished
group of people in the room today so I
greet Udall so my name is Stephanie and
I speak as myself
um I don't represent any organization I
am NOT a government employee I'm clearly
not indigenous but what I've discovered
in my spirit is that there is a place
for people who can come in and be
neutral it doesn't mean that their heart
is neutral because mine is not but to
choose to be neutral in a moment to
hopefully bring people together to work
through questions often that role is
holding up a mirror and saying this is
what I think I heard you say is and to
ask some clarification
sometimes it's asking a question three
or four different ways and trying to
allow those in the room to truly hear it
so I want to speak more about just the
role of mediation and that is a hope for
mine that there are others who will
choose to engage as invited I was
invited by chief arvo looking horse to
serve in this capacity many years ago
and started in 2007 what I saw for the
first time as a white woman with
definite privilege moving to a different
state to a territory that was clearly
Dakota and and these indigenous people
and I didn't know anything about the
land part of that is learning about the
people's land that you're living on and
and trying to do the best you can to
walk lightly with our environment and I
recognize that it is not my role and it
is not my position nor my goal to try to
fix anything in mediation it is not like
arbitration or going through the court
system where you have a judge who makes
a decision or an arbitration where you
bring the parties together and then
there's a statement that's made and
everybody lives with it
mediation is a is an arts of dialogue
and bringing people together to try to
find the space for how do we move this
forward but this is probably the most
important thing that I've learned in the
last 10 years is that peace is not the
goal
I believe that peace without justice is
unsustainable
and so often people come in as
peacemakers peace builders and they want
to fix the moment and they will not
address the hundreds of years or
whatever the issues are behind the
scenes the players are not at the table
to speak for themselves that could be a
role of a facilitator who can come in
and try to make that a more equitable
conversation not that the mediator says
it's I come from a sports background and
so I think about a referee and back to
hockey that I if you have a good referee
you don't see them in the game and that
the game plays and so it is the parties
that are the ones who create the space
to make things happen very quickly as a
follow-on and a brief answer please you
you didn't represent the Lakota
community and in holy elk has spoken
you know eloquently about you know that
perspective what can you tell us because
they're not here about the feelings in
the law-enforcement community and there
were lots of them on the other side I
mean what were their concerns in this
conflict
as somebody who is in the middle and
just like I cannot speak for Lakota
people or those who are at camp I cannot
speak for law enforcement either and I
know that sounds like a dodge from a
question but I must I cannot speak for
them and I think the biggest lessons are
this bringing people together for those
moments as camp closed trying to find
how and this was led by those who had
much more wisdom than I for them to say
how do we move forward for this next
three hours yes the ocean and and go to
Norway and this a bit Gamal said that
you do not represent the noosphere
company but rather the mining industry
as a whole and no way seems a lot calmer
at least at this point on the copper
mine proposal Norway is an early
signatory to the UN declaration it has a
careful process to accommodate its
intended to accommodate the rights of
the Sami population and yet you say this
process has become something of a
procedural quagmire going back and forth
lacking quality clarity for your site
how could you improve Norway to enable a
peaceful resolution between what you're
trying to do which is mine copper in a
land where the copper is as you say it's
not anywhere else you can't go somewhere
else for it and accommodate the concerns
of the indigenous communities and
environmental associations that are
allied with them thank you first of all
let me say that I think the two cases
are vastly different what I hear about
Standing Rock tells me that indigenous
people are still vulnerable but these
two cases are set they have different
implications they are set in different
political systems with different
policies call soon very the copper mine
in the
we're talking about is plant is an
example of Sami community with a
declining an aging population the mine
has strong local support the mayor tells
me it can bring new optimism and growth
and the ground owner argues that the
mining project will help safeguard the
Sami culture and language locally Norway
has among the world's most strict
regulations on environment health and
safety but also as you mentioned we have
rules on how to take into account Sami
purposes copper is a key component in
the green technology department as you
said one big challenge for us is the
procedural quagmire or the SoCs bahama
links hang in Mira Energy this that this
project has happened in it goes back and
forth and I believe it's a unworthy
strategy the Sami Parliament did not
accept the New Eden mineral act as far
as I understand it this is about three
things
it's about indigenous economical
compensation it's about zombies living
outside Finnmark
and it's about consultation and as an
industry we don't have any problems with
this in fact I invite to a discussion
how these issues can be implemented in
the mineralized and I believe you have a
common interest in that we both need the
predictability of the clear act my hope
would be to use this debate to address
these challenges and to forward them to
Norwegian politicians yes we'll go then
to the the obvious response that we will
look for from the president of the Sami
Parliament ie Lika Scootaloo a number of
questions implicit there you were saying
that you like the mining industry
are looking for clarity but that means
something very different for you well we
certainly want to change the mineral act
of Norway but I'm not sure that we want
the same changes as as the mineral
industry but first I would like to say
that also the matter of West and in Rock
and the North Dakota access pipeline is
a matter of solidarity for the sami
people so we recognize your struggles
and your struggles are also our
struggles and we hope to move forward
together I would like to say that copper
mining in nursery area in Palace Nouri
in in in Finnmark is we are opposing
strongly the project of several reasons
where the most important are the
disposal of mining waste into the fjord
where the fish fisheries are and also
because it is a kind of a land grab of
reindeer herding areas and I feel very
strongly about this because in the same
area the state of norway norwegian
authorities they claim there are too
many reindeers there not enough grazing
lands for all the rangers but they are
allowing land grabbing in the same area
last week a young man from one of the
reindeer herding districts that are are
having trouble with an east nusa mine he
was in the Supreme Court of Norway here
in Oslo defending his right to continue
his reindeer herding because the
authorities are saying to him that he
has to slaughter most of his herd
because they are not enough land for him
how can the same authorities allow
continual land grabbing in in reindeer
herding areas when they are telling us
that there is no room for reindeer herds
of today
it makes no sense to me and and I we
oppose it strongly so it sometimes it
seems like a big conspiracy they are
attacking us from different angles
but what gives me hope is that we are
still here we are still here after
hundreds of years of assimilation
policies we are still here and when it
comes to the community of qalam and the
claims that the copper mining will will
make the Sami language and culture
blossom in this Islamic community and I
ask you show me one indigenous community
where mining has been has made the
culture in the genus culture and
language blossom give me one example of
that I have tried to research it
question
specifically use you speak in protection
of traditional occupations of Sami
reindeer husbandry for example what is
your response to the mayor who is
referred to earlier who talked about the
fact that the economy of this region has
really dwindled in in recent decades is
economic development a priority and how
would you like to see economic
development come to the region well I'm
not sure if it's true because the humma
first area is the region where oil and
the oil and gas industry are booming in
Finnmark and this is the neighboring
village so I don't I don't think it's
it's quite true and that an unemployment
rate in this community is minimal so if
if this community where to where to
where should all the the workers come
from they would have to fly them in from
other parts of the world to work the
mine so I I don't think it's true that
it's the local community and the Sami
culture and and the salmon language
which will benefit from from from the
this project and I would have to say
that if farlis norisse wacom crawls
income earner if they really wanted to
fight for Sami language and culture why
did they refuse to join the
administrative area of Sami language
they didn't want to join up with other
Sami communities to protect the Sami
language it's it's difficult to me for
me to understand can we just get go
ahead very briefly we were included in
the response that you gave so I just
want to respond to that as well that the
you explained that we were different
than the Sami and I wanted to just let
you know that we are not we are not any
different we stand in solidarity with
the zombies against mining companies
against oil industries because we are
the same we have experienced the same
genocide we still live in the present
day genocide that is going on and they
are not they are in a very vulnerable
indigenous people and and you are
actively trying to make them extinct so
the Lakota people we stand in solidarity
with them because we are the same okay
thank you Elizabeth I feel compelled to
give you a very brief response because
but I don't want to go back and forth
too much and then I want to get to
professor of not quickly but go ahead
very shortly and we're not trying to
make them extinct mining is such was in
some areas was was challenged here we
are not in the backyard not in my
backyard business but we need the
minerals and copper is necessary for the
Green transits transition for
electrification etc how manifest was
mentioned yes how many first has seen a
very positive development and quarrel
soon living next to colleges first is
looking for a similar development and
sees the mine as a possibility for that
let me answer the question about the
position in the field shortly because
when you take out a mineral like copper
there's some residual and you need to
put it somewhere and this has been
decided putting in the field safely on
the bottom of the field it's in this
particular project it's been considered
that this is the best at least polluting
option and and it there's been they've
have been through a very thorough
environmental in
Association that the position is safe
the copper minerals will stay will be
stable they will be encapsulated by
natural deposition this particular or a
copper is among the cleanest ones in the
world see the position has been tried
locally before and life has come back
also in their substantial knowledge
about it based on several decades of
such practice in Lewisham mines and just
recently an EU Technical Working Group
acknowledged that Norway is doing this
in in a knowledgeable way so finally on
this panel for this round to Professor
or even Ravana you're a legal scholar on
indigenous affairs you are in the
University of Toronto but you've also
spent time in Indian country in in the
Upper Great Plains of the United States
you were in Standing Rock before getting
to commonalities that you see between
these two conflicts and where you might
see opportunity for some coming together
and crossing the divide I wonder if you
can reconcile some of what we've been
hearing in the dispute in you know in
the in the Crossland project I can say
yes thank you for the question and I can
say something about both the mining
industry there from a legal aspect there
is of course this contradiction to the
between the Norwegian Mining Act and the
Sami people there is a few very
important point is to benefit to the
indigenous people which is not ensured
in the Norwegian a mineral act there is
not a consistent consultation procedures
and when we go auto-da-fé in mercury
right not assure anything of indigenous
people elsewhere in the country and and
of course what is very much into focus
no it is the pasture of the reindeer
herders as the early casket out of the
Sun president told us there was a
Supreme Court case just a week ago where
a young reindeer herder had to defend
his land because the authorities has a
program to reduce numbers of reindeers
for sure we cannot compare it in the way
the American the white Americans reduced
the quantity of buffalos on the Prairie
but in any case it is method to decrease
the level of reindeer for the Indians
people so at the same time the argument
that that they should take more and more
land for for the mining industry
it doesn't fit it's not as sustainable
development' room for an accommodation
where do you see this proposal going in
the next few months it's likely to be
approved by the Norwegian authorities is
that correct
usually in Norway it's the Norwegian
state in the government who has the last
word so we the Norwegian estate in white
the Sami people to consultation there is
adopted a consultation agreement in 2005
which is rather good or was rather good
at that time but there have been a
development
for 12 years after that in 2007 Norway
endorsed the UN Declaration of Rights of
Indigenous people who say that the
international standard in such cases is
not consultation but consent and there
have also been a low group who has
presented a bill for consultation who
say that that the standard should be
consent so there is a time for Norway
also to go further when it comes to
dealing with the indigenous people and
to
involve them in the decision making
process not just inform them and tell
them and ask them to come to the table
and say if you are not agree we have the
last word okay I just wanted to take us
beyond these two to broader concepts
here
dr. Manchu earlier mentioned the
spectacle of electric lines electric
grid lines coming out of indigenous
lands and hydroelectric power going past
the communities and not providing
electricity for the local communities
are there scenarios in which the the
benefits can be more equitably shared
and is that an issue is it an issue of
cultural preservation as well as an
equitable sharing of whatever bounty is
being sought I'll ask you that question
and what I'd like anyone else to also
weigh and especially your new Chief Ed
John but I mean is that an issue is is
it the the bounty sharing that has not
been equitable through history and as it
still perceived as being inequitable and
is that an issue point in the mineral
act who should have a part of the profit
should it go to the land owner or should
it go to the indigenous people who have
their traditional lands in the area no
rich mineral act they are not in confirm
with ILO 169 who say that indigenous
people should benefit that an original
stage they defend themselves saying they
gave it to the landowner and the
landowner should provide it further to
the indigenous people but in fact we see
that isn't happen so so that's a it's
it's a main issue where the benefit from
the industry should go well would you
like like to see the benefits
distributed that would be more equitable
in your mind Madam President
that is maybe not the most important
question for us at this time because the
most important question for us would be
able to give a consent or not in the
question of if there should be
established mining on Sami territory
that is the most important issue for us
to be able to participate in the
decision-making process so any benefit
sharing that would be step two three
four five further down the line we want
a say in whether a mine should be
established or not and do you see
procedurally this is this evolving in in
this particular case well we said no to
the mineral act of Norway I believe it
was in 2006 or 2007 and that's ten years
with an so called
Sox pamellingson amira that Elizabeth
explained about we are hoping to explain
two bowls in which authorities and also
to the mineral industry that this is the
mother problem the biggest problem we
haven't agreed on the legal framework
and we will not legi agree on the legal
framework before we have a right to
consent or not to the mining so I hope
that one day then which authorities will
recognize this and address it in a
proper way and we are have been invited
to to the ministry ministry tomorrow
that are dealing with the mineral
industry so maybe that's kind of a
single signal okay chief Chief John you
have talked about Canada being at the
forefront I mean what we're talking
about our our systems in place but the
devil is in the details and they
implement
and there seems to be a great scarcity
of examples of where the implementation
of some of these elegant declarations
have has actually blossomed talk about
what Canada is doing that gives you hope
I think rightly pointed out what I think
is the essence of what what what is
needed here 60 years ago Lester Pearson
who was then the Prime Minister of
Canada was awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
here in his speech he talked about the
four phases of peace and then one of
these he talked about peace and power
now let me phrase it within the context
of what we're talking about here article
43 of the Declaration the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights speaks about
the 46 standards are the minimum
standards for the survival dignity and
well-being of the world's indigenous
peoples now what does that have to do
with anything well it is it is the
purpose of the Declaration after all so
when I come back to the question of
peace and power the notion of free prior
and informed consent is an embedded in
at least seventeen provisions of the
Declaration and so it's about
decision-making preparing informed
consent is about the ability of
indigenous peoples to make decisions
about their lands and their territories
and resources and in the Declaration it
also says that where development is to
take place in the indigenous lands that
the the state must consult and cooperate
with indigenous peoples to obtain their
free prior and informed consent so how
do you how do you make that work how
does it sue so that's the point I'm
that's the point is it's about a
decision-making process is not about
consultation consultations in the old
standard where you take a piece of paper
and wave it under the indigenous peoples
nose and proceed with the project
so here you have the the Sami Parliament
making decisions on behalf of the Sami
people and you have the state of Norway
the government making decisions that we
have the Norwegian people now what
happens if there's a conflict how do you
resolve that as governments these need
to be as you said you were having
discussions this week so in Canada what
what we have undertaken we have a
constitutional provision that recognizes
in the firm's our rights in 1982 we've
been in the Supreme Court of Canada then
the courts in Canada over 200 times to
find what those seventeen words in the
Constitution mean and and finally the
the courts have got to the point that
consent is a very important issue where
there's where there are deep impacts
that are taking place and I can't think
of anything more important than when
you're impacting on the rights of
indigenous peoples so what we have done
with the Government of Canada and the
provincial government where I come from
is that they have accepted the
declaration to implement in
collaboration with us we're reviewing
the environmental process we're
reviewing the federal national
legislation on the National Energy Board
for pipelines interprovincial pipelines
we're reviewing the environmental
assessment act in Canada were reviewing
federal legislation on fisheries
that's important here and we're
reviewing federal legislation on
navigable waters but with our
involvement in the process and so what
we talk about is Co developing
legislation not for the government
simply they talk to us and then proceed
as they wish the standards are changing
and the Government of Canada under this
Prime Minister and we have a Minister of
Justice an Aboriginal woman from the
western part where I come from were
absolutely proud of her her name is
Julie Wilson rabo she's in this very
incredibly important place where she has
been able to educate those who are
members of parliament and so here
one of the really big issues is that
there's either racism that exists or
intolerance and at the very best you can
count indifference people who simply
don't care so we have to become our own
advocates okay so you've seen some hint
of political will move in Canada where
you actually might see some
implementation we have did I say very
little time we're almost out of it so I
want to offer each of the panelists
maybe thirty Seconds to sum up and
hopefully with an optimistic note on
where you see the political will to
start crossing the divide okay about
sharing benefits I think we have
suggested giving it to the Sami
Parliament so if that would be helped
let me also comment on the free inform
prior consent free is fine priorities
fine informed is fine when it comes to
consent as much as far as you can go and
it should be in everything should be any
consideration but I respect to know when
the government has says that the mining
project is not good enough and and as
long as the other considerations have
been taken into
being considered I think that we should
also respect yes because copper is
necessary we need it for electrification
bringing people out of poverty
so mining has a role and indigenous
people have role and we want to be
present at the same time and that's
where the discussion should go along how
can we both be present at the same time
professor what can stimulate that
political will to start walking down and
crossing that divide for me also free
prior and informed consent is important
and opposite Elizabet I think the only
important water is consent and and if
you are speaking about the individual if
a weaker party say no she have rights to
say no that's a big focus on that
everywhere it should be the same if it's
in its minority culture protecting their
land say no against intervention from
it's a little bit surprised that this
should be that kind of a big discussion
it's obvious that you should have rights
to say no when somebody inter went in
your land
despite the asymmetry of the power
equation of this it's of course a
question what kind of where the
intervention is done but if it's in the
heart of your model on or your
traditional land or or as in in in u.s.
or in the Lakota land a tribal land
you should have rights to say no okay
president casketed oh well we are
fighting for our future as a people and
for some kind of control over our faith
so so this is important to us and we
will continue the struggle we are
willing to consult with the authorities
on on in Norway on better mineral act
for the future that will give us the
possibility to to give consent when
when that is in in question but I think
for the new suitcase we would probably
not have given consent if we were able
to and that is our position when it
comes to the the new city new seed
mining what gives me hope for the future
is of course that the mineral resources
they are in the ground they are not
going anywhere
and they can give it they can be in the
ground for several generations forward
if we do not have an acceptable legal
framework if we do not have the right
technology to to to extract it without
destroying the environment so so I'm in
that case of the Misti scale for the
future we are not in a hurry
chief 30 seconds important to understand
that indigenous people are not opposed
to development of resources it needs to
be sustainable for sure
it's a lot of times it's where the
development is going to take place and
the magnitude of that development how it
impacts so here's the situation as I see
we have a Sami Parliament that makes
decisions we have the Norwegian
government that makes decision so if for
example and Canada makes a decision and
we our own nations make decisions a lot
of people expect that the government
decision and respected if it's yes or no
but when indigenous governments like the
Sami Parliament for example makes a
decision then people say what gives you
the right to make that decision and
that's really the the incredible
challenge and we fought for a long time
at the United Nations to establish these
standards that allows us to make
decisions about our respective lands
territories and resources and and I
think that's you know that there's a
hope there that that that collaboration
will take place and let me quote let me
quote them justice Rosalia Bella hear
about human rights she noted the
distinction between in many ways we are
crossroads and human rights justice and
the choices we make will determine that
not only how history will judges but
also what kind of world we will live on
civil rights is about treating everyone
the same Human Rights is about
acknowledging people's differences so
they can be treated as equals and then
she said at the end indifference is
injustice is incubator it's not what you
stand for with what you stand up for and
then we must never forget how the world
looks to those who are vulnerable and I
would I would put the indigenous peoples
in that category vulnerability in
relation to the power in asymmetry that
you talk about so these standards that
the UN
an important balance in mechanism for
indigenous people state relations that's
how we cross the divide or that's how we
look should look at the divide that the
topic here okay it's definitely what
gives you hope in 30 seconds well you've
seen a beautiful snapshot of what it
means to have dialogue and people in the
room together who have difference of
opinions and trying to move it forward
but this is on the legal frame many of
these questions about how will things
play out in courts how will it play out
in government what happens on the
sidelines though with people who are
grassroots so we're living this when
people come in when law enforcement come
in one of the things that gives me hope
is a conversation that hopefully will
continue about how do we protect those
who are in a spot of medical who are
assisting those when there's a front
line action and who protects the media
are they able to go and can they reports
many things about Standing Rock did not
get reported for many months until there
were injuries and so how did how was it
our voice before that happens and how
are the the reporters allowed to come in
to share that message with the world so
creating a framework for keeping medical
media ministry will keep the m's going
mediation legal observers those who are
coming in in the neutral space to help
keep that safe while it works out
through the court system and so I'm
hopeful for that as well okay there are
many things that that would crush the
divide but at the very foundation of it
the American government needs to
recognize that we are a sovereign people
we are capable we are intelligent we are
entitled to be who we are and it's time
for them to acknowledge us as such we
are a nation within what they call their
country and it's time for them to honor
the the laws that they've created it's
time for them to honor the treaties that
they've written and the promises that
they've written on those papers
okay
see if you mentioned that you mentioned
and cited justice Abella on in
difference being the incubator of
injustice and a good part of that might
well be the fact that these issues and
these stories are not widely reported
either of them in the major population
centers they're I was told that that the
nasir controversy is hardly reported or
visible in the Oslo area and the Dakota
conflict was not very widely reported
until it really escalated and I take
some responsibility for that as a as a
media person and so I'm especially
thankful to the Nobel folks for raising
or helping raise the visibility of this
issue in the grand tradition of this
institution and I want to thank all of
you for your time as little as it was
and thank you dr. Manchu thank you so
much for coming and this dialogue will
continue tomorrow as well
you